-Good evening.
I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night." We hope
everybody's doing well tonight.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're gonna get to the news.
President Biden said yesterday
that he plans to deliver
a speech about aid for Ukraine.
And to make sure people tune in,
he promised to go
no teleprompter.
[ Laughter ]
While leaving
the courtroom yesterday
during the third day
of his civil fraud trial,
former President Trump
told reporters
he would rather be in Iowa.
And now he's also facing
one count of perjury.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new study,
mortgage applications
have hit a nearly
three-decade low,
which is bad news for people
who just lost their house.
[ Laughter ]
New York Mayor Eric Adams
began a four-day tour
of Latin America yesterday
and plans to dissuade migrants
from traveling to the city.
Apparently, he's gonna do it
by telling them
that he's the mayor.
[ Laughter ]
In a new interview, Republican
Senator Markwayne Mullin
criticized Florida
Congressman Matt Gaetz
and said that Gaetz
had bragged
that he would crush
erectile dysfunction medicine
and, quote, "chase it
with energy drinks
so he could go all night."
He added...
[ Laughter ]
He added that sometimes
Gaetz would even have
a woman with him.
[ Laughter and groans ]
[ Laughter continues ]
After The New York Times
reported yesterday
that federal prosecutors
are investigating
his drinking habits,
Rudy Giuliani
told reporters, quote,
"I do not have
an alcohol problem.
I have never had
an alcohol problem."
Rudy, man...
they're giving you
a perfect excuse.
Take the off-ramp.
Do you really want people
to think you helped
an insurrectionist, went
to the wrong Four Seasons,
leaked hair dye,
and wore these shorts
while you were
stone-cold sober?
[ Laughter ]
After it was reported...
They put -- If you wear
those shorts,
that's a -- that's
a drunk driving test.
They pull you over and they go,
"You want to put these on?"
If you're like,
"Yeah, I'll put them on,"
they're like,
"Get in the car."
After it was reported
that prosecutors
are investigating
his drinking habits,
Rudy Giuliani
told reporters, quote,
"If I have an alcohol problem,
I should be in the Guinness
Book of World Records."
But it turns out
he already is.
[ Laughter ]
Russian President Vladimir Putin
turns 71 on Saturday.
He's gonna celebrate
by pushing a cake off a balcony.
[ Laughter and groans ]
Ohhhh.
You guys must love cake.
[ Laughter ]
In a new statement
about climate change,
Pope Francis criticized
fossil fuel companies
and said the transition
toward renewable energy
is, quote, "not progressing
at the necessary speed."
And you know you're in trouble
when the Catholic Church
thinks you're stuck
in the past.
[ Laughter ]
A resident of
the Florida retirement community
The Villages
was arrested recently
after he allegedly
stockpiled nearly $2,000 worth
of erectile dysfunction drugs
to sell,
continuing the long tradition
of drug dealers yelling,
"Say hello to my little friend."
[ Laughter ]
And finally, Katmai
National Park in Alaska
today kicked off its annual
Fat Bear Week contest.
Unfortunately, since they were
all shamed last year,
they went on Ozempic.
[ Laughter and awws ]
[ Laughs ]
That was a monologue, everybody!
We got a good show
for you tonight.